ROB DODSON: The web is in the
spotlight at Microsoft's build
conference and how is TCP a
lot like the seventh grade?
I'm Rob Dodson.
This is "Lazy Web."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER 1: Would you like
to hear the name of the new web
browser in Windows 10?
ROB DODSON: The web is a serious
player at Microsoft's build
conference.
The team reveals Microsoft
Edge, their new browser,
formerly called Project
Spartan; Visual Studio Code,
which splits the gap
between Editor and IDE
and runs on all
platforms; Project Vorlon
for remote debugging and
testing your JavaScript;
and ManifoldJS for hosted apps.
You can find more info
over at dev.modern.ie.
MALE SPEAKER 2:
The right response
to what's up is-- what's up.
ROB DODSON: Network latency
kills fast page experiences.
In this talk from
SmashingConf, Paul Irish
explains speed
index and how TCP is
a lot like his former
seventh-grade self
saying hi to the
coolest kid in school.
Live performance audits
demonstrate common pitfalls
from actual sites, and
there's even a few bonus
dev tools goodies at the end.
Keep track of your
site's performance
with this helpful dashboard,
an open source project,
combining Graphite,
Grafana, and SightSpeed.io
The tool lets you
measure metrics
like speed index for your
most important pages,
configure world
performance budgets,
and even use web page tests.
You can add your own
metrics to measure,
and best of all, the project
is deployable as a set
of docker containers.
What if you could write
mobile apps with Dart?
Eric Seidel from
Google demonstrates
Sky, an experimental,
open source
framework for writing mobile
apps at this year's Dart
Summit.
Designed to produce
120 Hertz experiences,
Sky aims to take the best
parts of the Chrome and Dart
ecosystem and combine them
with an easy-to-deploy package
for native apps.
Page weight doesn't
equal user wait.
Scott Jehl from
Filament Group explains
that just because the
site is resource heavy,
it doesn't mean the initial
experience should be slow.
By focusing on network latency
and render blocking assets,
and leveraging tools, like
WebPagetest and PageSpeed
Insights, Jehl
demonstrates how he
was able to knock 8.5 seconds
off a site's initial render
time without changing
the actual page weight.
Priority tasks move to
the front of the line.
Recently discussed
on the Chromium blog,
Chrome's new scheduler
allows the browser
to rearrange the
order it runs tasks,
such as responding to
clicks, and paning to screen.
Previously, the
scheduler handled tasks
the same way that a bank
handles a queue of customers.
But in Chrome 41, urgent
and priority tasks
can now skip to the
front of the line.
This can dramatically
improve scroll performance
as demonstrated in this demo.
That's it for this week, folks.
Take a deep breath,
enjoy the visuals,
and to all you LazyWebbers out
there, thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]